[Musica]
ma
sento che la forza trascendere il mio
spirito è dentro la bella tutti ragazzi
e benvenuti a questo nuovo video dove
sono giustamente vestito da sì perché
oggi faremo un play molto particolare è
uscita la nuovissima è fantastica ma
andremo a vederla espansione di the sims
dove c'è allora prima di cominciare
ragazzi puoi togliere questo rumore di
spada laser a giampiero grazie molto
molto gentile perfetto prima di
cominciare ragazzi su the sims ti fanno
fare un test per vedere a che fazione di
star wars appartieni quindi mi sembra
giusto provare iniziare a fare questo
test e vedere se finisco nel primo
ordine canaglie c'è un modo per vedere
questa cosa partiamo subito col quiz mi
levo tutto quanto dipende da quale
fazione appartengo
vediamo cosa esce fuori del quale senza
è che già il quale che senza apostrofo
mi mi riempie d'orgoglio italiano
meraviglioso assumere controllo della
galassia perito sin così è più prezioso
giusto no potere come si sposta per il
pianeta ma chi può con un'ala x9 runcio
la patente che apre come un clandestino
come ictus in cosa si porterà a casa
un sit in o una spada laser
ecco lo sono faccio parte delle canaglie
grazie maurizio alberghini e già
visitato l'avamposto della guglia né io
ci vado subito a prescindere perché
comunque ragazzi adesso il problema qual
è il problema che vi devo unire alle
canaglie lo faccio io eccolo battuti dal
benvenuto ti servirà critica la il
credito galattico innanzitutto vi
presento che personaggio che non me lo
presenta si chiama osvaldo geni madonna
martin garris robotico va dal osvaldo
jedi preso bene ciao ragazzi omissioni
delle canaglie guarda un po la faccia il
nuovo attiva di giocare con me a sabac
non mike hanno ricevuto per migliore per
conoscersi meglio tanto così da perdere
potreste detto da parte loro amicizia
va bene fino al vecchio fitto la
missione meraviglioso fulvio quelle che
mi sta tenendo da parte un po come tutta
la felicità per affari lo prendo io lo
faccio io
parla conto con da drappi usalo per
vivere la porta del mio amico e per
portarmi il suo parco e volevo dire il
mio pacco ancora peggio d'accordo
splendido chiedi alla gente in giro
provato stessa come ottenere un
connettore mi scusi mi scusi signor
storm trooper lei che vive qua e
pattuglia qua mi sono due domande 1 dove
si trova nelle mutande nuove negozi di
biancheria e due atomi sta scortando un
altro stop entro breve dove si trova un
connettore ciò che fuso ragazzi però la
vostra maschera dovrebbe così c'è
filtrare l'aria tipo non so le
mascherine no o fai gli acquisti nella
tana dell antichità di gioconda o
perfetto
buongiorno puzzo di kakà e tutto il
resto ho bisogno di un connettore quelle
cose che fitna la playstation connettore
1 salve a un impugnatura più quello mi
dà mi dà una spada facciamola
per tutte perché almeno o una spada
teoricamente al connettore cielo o anche
una spada laser ago ho preso i pezzi non
solo unirli non so come vai vai a cagare
sulla sedia bravo
non lo so ragazzi comunque con eto'o già
ottieni il pacco per hondo laggiù il
quartiere del primo ordine usando tutte
le prove però andò voglio raggiungere ma
mi ha però una doccia si batterà per
l'amor di dio
continuerò quel personaggio che puzza
tutto il tempo quartiere le primarie
ragazzi ho bisogno di un pacco da te il
parco al pozzo ne va in giro con la
spada composta vedrai un pannello di
controllo sulla parete davanti a dani di
tropea e viola l'opera girare la porta
di sicurezza un pannello di controllo
analizza il pannello di controllo ecco
qua analizzato e ora violiamo questo
tipo l'amazon box dove spiccano i pacchi
che vedo che bravo col tablet stai
violando lo sto continuando analizzare
che devo fà viola riscrittura il codice
se io ho studiato i formati casa almeno
servirà qualcosa giorno
agi attenzione gino alla sigla porti
sequenza per acquisita è appreso nel
pacco vai veloce e feroce fi veloce file
cielo mamma mia che fenomeno bravo dov'è
entrato non ho capito non entrato ma è
entrato quindi va bene ma ho tenuto il
banco effetto consegna al parco tondo
let's go back è perfetto ci ho messo sei
ore ma ha posto tre anni di informatica
studiarti sul sito del 60 per prendere
un pacco di amazon dentro una porta però
fa niente consegna il pacco perfetto
sempre una bella frase della legge su
the sims
i gol sono novellino di grado 1 delle
canaline e perfetto previs locati
crediti galattici interazione truffa
connettore va bene ma posso comprare i
connettori da lui adesso davvero truffa
per ottenere crediti no vabbè ma non
posso trovare lui è il mio lui è il mio
datore di lavoro tra virgolette troviamo
gli altri posso trovare
lo zio come sto provando a truffare la
gente ma la gente giustamente non è
contenta va bene puoi darmi altre
missioni mister ramon nodo cananda come
si chiamano imparerò maisto nome allora
una buona dritta viaggio d'affari
oggetto smarrito una buona occasione
hanno trovato merce gli affari vanno a
gonfie vele teste con un viaggio di
lavoro di del tutto lecito ma ben
preparati per il viaggio d'affari
clicca sul millenium falcon per andare
direttamente sul millenium falcon va
bene va il viaggio d'affari con la
macchinina pratica prendo le gioie guido
per milano la stessa cosa da una roba
pazzesca
quindi via io falcon sussulta mente
viene bersagliato la raffica laser ma
costava veramente quindi saggia
decisioni mancini volanti non hanno
portato minuti di buono scherzando
raggiungi canone principale massaggi
cosa sai fare a stop spara inquinanti o
sparati colpi la vedendo spara i pirati
giovani ti fanno combattere ma veramente
su becca fa compiere un giro e la morte
al falcone posiziona nave sopra i pirati
al che osvaldo prende la mira e spara
bomba perché voglio dire continua la
missione ad ispezionare il relitto
ispezionate lo prende tutte con noi
avete cioè razionate tutto va bene tra
la vera grande fuoco plus si abbatte sul
gruppo e si pare il fuoco si interrompe
sbando approfitta del momento di passare
all'azione fuggiti al falcon va bene
possono fare le altre cose sono stato
sfilato con le spade vita che per ora
non solo skillato per niente prove hondo
porge una borsa di crediti ecco la tua
parte amico mio come deciso all 80
società menti per cento a te osvaldo lo
fissa impassibile bene bene sono
impressionato cena ce la facciamo 70 30
quanto guadagnate un'asta roba ma non ha
dato niente discutere del piano forse
perché devo discutere finalmente le
viaggio da fare invece per concludere la
faccenda quando è tornato eccoti qua
discuti dell'esito del viaggio d'affari
così almeno melo da crack credo mi da
una parte dei soldi quant'era 25250
grazie acquisisci frammenti informativi
in giro aprile casse di rifornimenti di
oli pannelli o parla con la gente in
giro in modo da quelle informazioni
preziose ma poi a caso vediamo se seduce
i fermi
poi voglio vedere con i miei occhi con i
miei fammi vedere non ha funzionato
peccato reputazione non che io abbia
chissà che reputazione ma vediamo posso
provare intimidire qualcuno intimi divo
intimidire la gente non so perché sono
la prima volta che se le ssis mi capita
di fare quello che intimidisce la gente
non mi e mai su centi mi dici tu sei
terribilmente insistente il cotone non
mi piaccio dio dio dirmi quello che sai
canaglia
questa non è una cosa che siano in
vigore e dunque può succedere
può succedere quando che le informazioni
o far milano uguale alla fine comunque
la gente ecco qua e quindi genere allo
sbando si odia va bene con informazioni
che ti occorrono lasciami in pace
no veramente condice adesso parlano
tranquilli presentazione divertente la
nostra funzionando
mi manca un corso informativo solo da
lui
intimi discinti mi chiamo la gente ma è
l'ultimo ad intimidire questo qua e va
bene tutto quello che so perché mi lasci
in pace cioè la dovrei aver fatta
ragazzi ok cinque elementi informativi
raccoglie i frammenti volevo dire
raccogliere in the tablet rapporto è
completo ai racconti informazioni
sufficienti da vendere i mercati neri va
bene ce l'ho fatta almeno siamo a posto
mio lavoro anche oggi è fatto meglio che
lo youtube truffatore tenere a contatto
di tenere comunque non lo è non li vendo
adesso ritengo lì dal rapporto a dongo
sa bene dove sei tu il mercato nero
hondo no le votazioni pressione caragli
e più sono bravo a fare la canaglia e
comunque e quindi ragazzi questa è stata
la mia esperienza come canaglia però
effettivamente se devo dirvi la verità
non credo di essere nato per fare quello
che frega la gente che ruba i soldi alle
persone in giro che chiacchiera le robe
io ho fatto un informazione uscito con
60 lega che ha però vabbè
concentratevi io mi concentro ci vediamo
in giro se vedete un incappucciato
rigira so io non mi fanno né kringe sono
io che voglio fare così
[Musica]